yo speaking of speaking of music man
don't
don't you feel like drake and future
just need to go back to the
what a time to be a live era of making
dark moody trap music made for late
night drives around atlanta while you're
sipping on a cup of lean
don't you feel that way totally
you know couldn't have said it better
myself someone tweeted this [ __ ]
reddit post it's on our drizzy i was
crying dude
and that was the caption
you know it's some [ __ ] suburban
white kid too of course
you know it is i mean but it's so good
man like
it is he is he is he getting is he
trolling us you know what i mean like
this is so
funny this is such good coffee posture
right here man like
i gotta hold on i'm gonna click this i
need to i need to memorize this
bro where the f but damn it's been a lot
of [ __ ] happening in two days
yeah i think
181 upvotes yeah yeah yeah well at the
time i mean that's just probably popping
now but
guys listen i need you all to memorize
this and use
make this your opinion just go into like
twitter threads and just
say this [ __ ]
yeah man drake and future just need to
go back to that what a time to be alive
air of making dark moody trap music made
for late night drives around atlanta
while you're sipping on a cup of lean
you know
all right tristan all right tristan
i was just picturing like being in a
studio being an
intern and saying this [ __ ] and just
just
completely speaking out of turn
so i'm skinny skinny like white kid
yo if i may if i may interject with my
opinion
i think drake and future need to go back
to the what but what is this
what era of making dark moody trap music
made for late night drives around
atlanta while you're sipping on a cup of
lean
they're like man clean
the [ __ ] bathroom what do you who let
you in here man
[ __ ] [ __ ] we're in we're in
sacramento dude what are you yeah yeah
what are you yeah
we're in oregon man
have you ever been to atlanta yeah i
went to buckhead once with my parents
this was sick
now i'm just thinking of the most
immature [ __ ] just
eating your girl out and you [ __ ]
lift your head up do you ever feel like
drake and future need to go back to
making the
time
making dark moody trap music made for
late night drives around atlanta while
you're sipping on a cup of lean
what let's go right back to it
just intense just hitting it from the
back intense
hey do you ever feel like
ah draken future just i need to go back
to that what a time to be alive era make
a dark
moody trap music paper late night cries
around
like sipping on a cup of lean all right
uh that reminds me of the little dickie
show and he's when he's [ __ ] his girl
and he looks up and it's just like the
drake poster yeah yeah
just imagine finishing rolling over
girls like how is that for you i just
can't stop thinking about the fact that
drake and fusion need to go back to the
one time to be a library of making dark
movie trap music made for late night
drives around atlanta while you're
sitting on a couple later oh my god
oh man
oh man
[Laughter]
i've never had a poster with eyes
does that make sense no i've never
i've purposely never had a poster in my
room that had eyeballs
because if they follow you around yeah i
just i didn't like
that idea of just someone just feeling
like someone is just like looking
you know um not not like in a creepy way
it's just like a
i don't know like just just be i'm weird
right and just feel like they're real so
regardless of what i'm doing it's more
like you know i don't want someone
judging me
you know yeah i don't know you ever
heard that creepypasta
what the dude the photographer that goes
out into the woods
to shoot birds he's a bird photographer
no and he's out deep in the woods
shooting the um
yellow-bellied uh stork pigeon
okay okay and uh he gets he keeps going
deeper and deeper and deeper into the
woods
and it gets dark and he can't figure out
how to get out he doesn't know because
it's too dark
and all of a sudden he comes upon a
cabin in the woods
okay and so he's like okay i'll just
i'll just stay here for the night right
oh okay so he goes inside right
okay and it's very creepy you know it's
kind of dark in there it's
he said hello opens the door hello
no one's in there and he goes in and
there's a bed
and so he's like okay i'll just get some
rest and then and then i'll get out in
the morning
and he uh you know as he's falling
asleep he looks up and he sees all these
crazy portraits on the wall of these
people with these
warped faces and all of them are staring
directly at them it seems like they are
right
it's like the same thing you're talking
about the eyeballs and okay in the thing
right it's so creepy the portraits are
warped faces and they're all
you know just staring at him super
creepily and he gets he gets a good
night rest and he wakes up in the
morning
he looks up and all he sees her windows
i think you're trying to go for
something here so i'm um
windows hm
come on
weird
that's some scary [ __ ] dude yeah it's
pretty scary when you don't
go down your face [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i felt it dude i read that one time and
i i freaked out i didn't do it justice
oh you were serious i thought you were
trying to do like no no i wasn't when i
wasn't serious in your face
no no really yeah no that was a real
story that i'd read one time but
i [ __ ] it up completely oh okay
i thought you were i for sure thought
you were doing a windows balls in your
mouth
no but i should have yeah yeah god damn
it that would have been the perfect
opportunity that's why i was getting
scheduled i'm like when
does are you trying to
when those balls fit down your feet i
was like i'm doing the math
i'm doing the windows window
[ __ ] i should have done that windows
nuts in your mouth
no that's just a classic creepy pasta
that i read one time
i i remember the one about like the
smell of copper
and it was like i don't know some i
don't know
some ghost [ __ ] in the woods it doesn't
matter
you